Sam and art are incredible Visionaries
they're so
good and action me and girls the story
is still so
relevant it's not a remake it's like a
rediscovery that is TI she means that's
great the original it was so well done
but we wanted to go deeper into the
Journey of these characters and
musicality just allows you to do that I
don't care
you are they know how to shoot music
really well and with like a fresh
take K it girl they wanted it to feel
like something we had never seen before
they had incredible ideas for the movie
to feel Dynamic and
exciting every take and every scene they
come in with so much energy a power
Dynamic they're amazing creative
Geniuses to be honest so true this movie
it's a good time it's super fun
audiences will really enjoy it you could
be really hot if we change like
everything oh no she didn't yeah
yeah